Male northern elephant seals
know who their rivals are on the beach.
They don’t even have to see the other guy.
They remember his voice
and the rhythm in his call.
Humans do the same thing
when we listen to other people's voices.
That’s how we can put a name to a voice,
even without seeing someone
For elephant seals,
learning and remembering other males’ calls
is a matter of survival.
Every winter, the males gather at rookeries
from Northern California to Baja Mexico,
to fight and mate.
They fight for females--
raising their front flippers and rhythmically roaring.
By playing back natural and modified calls
to a seal colony,
scientists showed that
males remember each other’s voices.
When subordinate males heard
an alpha’s call that was sped-up or slowed down,
they stayed put.
But they fled
if the call was similar to the alpha’s normal one.
Subordinate males are usually smaller than the alphas,
and they move away
when they hear a dominant male call.
Males that don’t move away are attacked.
Alphas violently lunge at competitors,
sometimes causing serious—even lethal—injuries.
So it makes sense for the male elephant seals
to memorize their rivals’ voices.
They need to use those sounds
to decide on the best strategy:
flee or fight.